first off
these are a little dried shrimp you can
buy them anywhere
they smell almost sort of of the seabed
into the pestle mulch for this salad
inspired by my travels across thailand
i'm starting by making a wonderfully
spicy paste a little salt in there
in
just break them up this paste is like a
staple ingredient in thailand that's
what we're looking for almost it's like
a powder
right next just one clove of garlic
slice up the garlic
and get that into the pest and water
bird's eye chili incredibly hot powerful
but wow
it does give an amazing kick to the
paste
in
to the mix
now a couple of tablespoons of brown
caster sugar
that softens the blow with a chili and
then just to give that nice sour taste a
little bit of hot water into this
tamarind paste it's really tart but
sweet paste
one tablespoon in
fish sauce
now it's got that almost sort of pickly
smell slightly salty but the flavor is
intense two tablespoons and bring that
together
and give it a really good mix
some lime juice
in half another touch of tartness
the pace is nice and thick and
fragrant but it's got the heat the
sourness the tartness
incredible
green papaya stand it up and give it a
little peel you can find green papaya
and local asian shops and bigger
supermarkets and as it doesn't weld like
more delicate veg it's perfect for
robust salads like this i grate it
look
that's what i want these
thin slithers
next a nice
rich
sweet banana shalom
[Music]
nice
some carrot
carrot gives it another texture
now little that and mix it
[Music]
finish that off with thai basil and
fresh coriander
thai basil is a
much more fragrant
basil it's stronger and it's slightly
thicker as well
like papaya and tamarind paste you can
get thai basil in good supermarkets and
independent asian stores but normal
basil works well too
next prepare the crunchy topping
pan on and toast some peanuts
chop the nuts but it gives a really nice
crunch
in they go
roll them around the pan
gas off
and just stick them out
now for the exciting palm we're gonna
dress the salad
nice spoon of dressing in to the papaya
mix that in
and then finally
a nice general sprinkling
roasted
nuts
and that is one delicious very fragrant
very robust
green papaya salad
so easy to make and guaranteed not to go
limp a perfect party salad
and with such incredible colors textures
and bold exciting flavors it's sure to
grab your guests attention spicy chutney
with chutney standing by in the fridge
you can always add that special little
touch to a simple supper prove that
thinking ahead always pays off
pan on start toasting those spices keep
the pan nice and low cumin
very aromatic very fragrant and it's
almost like a light spice
next nice little coriander seeds
coriander in now you're going to get a
bit of heat in the chutney mustard seeds
well smaller than coriander seeds but so
much more powerful mustard seeds in
now
curry leaves
they don't actually smell much dry but
the flavor they give off is
extraordinary coli's in
really important not to burn them
otherwise you'll
have that bitter taste
across the chutney keep the gas nice and
low the secret is sort of toasting them
so it releases that oil and intensifies
the spice touch of salt
and then a couple of small powerful
chilies keep them whole
no one's going to eat them but it gives
that real nice burst of heat
now let them toast gently there we're
not gonna chop the onion we're gonna
grate it
why
because it sort of breaks down to a
really nice puree in the chutney when
you grate it hold the root in the palm
of your hand and just push
nice long
grates
i want those nice long shards
look i've almost got a nice sort of
onion puree but it's nice and clear
a touch of olive oil
spices nicely toasted onions in
[Music]
three nice cloves of garlic
lightly crushed some
[Music]
lay it nice and flat and just slice the
garlic
nice thin slices
garlic in
your time to get the owners caramelised
beautifully will really reap rewards in
the long run
tamarind paste and sugar in with the
sugar first three nice tablespoons of
sugar
that will give a really nice syrup
effect sort of nice rich syrupy texture
to the chutney
tamarind paste
you can get tamarind paste in most delis
and the big supermarkets
it's really nice thickening asian but it
gives that tartness the chutney and it's
sort of rich sugary spicy
next in with my coconut add four nice
tablespoons that'll give a nice body and
a really nice texture to the chutney
cook that coconut out and now add the
carrot
grated
the carrot just gives the chutney really
nice sort of crunch
but also helps to sort of cool down the
spice
carrots in
the water comes out the carrot flavors
the chutney beautifully but gives that
nice sort of vibrant bright color to it
as well
and grating it almost sort of it cooks
instantly but i want a bit of texture
through here
turn down the gas and just let that
simmer for five minutes
if the carrots aren't that moist and
juicy then put a couple of tablespoons
of water in there to help it along
now
just cook that out
for five minutes
just as those carrots start going nice
and soft don't overcook them you want
that nice texture in there slightly
spicy slightly sweet
gas off
keep those chillies in there for that
it's beautiful
nice and gooey delicious and
ready to go in his jar as that sits in
the fridge
just gets better and better and better
i love to eat this chutney with
cold meats or even cold fish but with
ham it's amazing
it's a really nice way of living up the
ham
just sort of roll it up
get a nice spoon of chutney
i mean it looks fantastic
chutney onto the plate
and serve and that is a
nice little
gem in the fridge that is worth prepping
in advance for
vietnamese style fresh prawn rolls
one of the keys to cooking for crowds is
creating the atmosphere and that buzz
getting your guests to sort of almost
get involved and dip in and dip out this
is an exciting
fragrant wrap that is so easy to do
first off soak the noodles these are
thin glass noodles basically bring the
kettle up to the boil
and just pour just let them steep there
for a couple of minutes
the noodles are for my prawn rolls as
they soak i'm gonna make a spicy dipping
sauce to go with them
start off with sugar we're trying to
create that sweet
sour salty but a really nice sort of
heated sauce as well
rice wine vinegar that will dissolve the
sugar
fish sauce now that's going to give it
its saltiness
next the chili i want the seeds left in
because i want some power
chilli in
a little bit of garlic
don't need to chop it too finely just
slice it take a spring onion just top
and tail them slice
slices bring it in nice and thinly so it
sort of
almost permeates that dipping sauce
i grew up with the love of spring rolls
but on the back of my visit to vietnam
it sort of transformed my respect for a
spring roll
give that a little mix
a little bit of coriander and fresh mint
roll them up
and chop
herbs in
there's no olive oil in there
there's no cream there's no butter it's
just a really nice light
dipping sauce and wow all those senses
going on
now we're gonna make the filling for the
wraps a really nice fresh noodle salad
rinse the noodles in cold water then
chop them into bite-sized lengths
prawns peeled and cooked slice them up
the prawns give a really nice sweetness
next the vegetables i want crunch
freshness texture baby gem lettuce and
just shred that
lettuce next spring onion the good news
about these wraps is that you can make
them up in advance sit them in the
fridge and then take them out literally
seconds
before your guests arrive
peel the carrot
so you got really nice fresh
crunchy carrot
now fresh mint fresh basil and fresh
coriander together sounds a little bit
bizarre but it tastes amazing don't hold
back with the herbs they'll really help
make the filling vibrant fresh and
aromatic
finally touch a lime
just squeeze that fresh lime juice over
there a couple of tablespoons of your
dipping sauce
don't put too much in there it just
makes all the filling too wet just give
that
a really good mix that's a very quick
simple salad to eat now but
let's get it into a wrap
now take your rice paper wrap literally
30 seconds in warm water you can get
rice paper wraps from your local asian
supermarket or buy them online
gently lift it out of the water
there beautiful lay it
carefully
onto your board
place the mixture
at the bottom
don't over fill it
because it'll be a nightmare to roll
fold them over first nice and tightly
halfway then tuck in the ends
and make sure
nothing's coming out the sides
beautiful
it's so light
fragrant incredibly simple to do
and there you go
a very delicious fragrant
asian wrap
certainly different to the chinese
spring rolls i grew up with
you